thank you so much michael the admiration
is mutual you all do such great work uh
and i've already had such a wonderful
day
uh seeing old friends and brand new grad
students full of ideas so it's really a
pleasure to be here
my talk today is called should you
believe wikipedia
an introduction to social and virtue
epistemology with questions about the
utility of philosophy for hci
as i was getting
uh ready to uh preparing my
talk earlier this week uh i uh
i'm a packrat i have a lot a digital
packrat not a physical packrat
i have a lot of old emails that i never
deleted
and i actually was
able to find an email from me to
terry winograd with the abstract of
my talk from december 1997.
uh i i'll let you guys read that while i
talk
uh i think it's fascinating to me
that i am still addressing
these questions uh what benefit
do online communities bring to their
members how are they designed
uh i tweeted this and james
asked so the grocery store clerk how is
he doing
well it turns out he's uh my college
roommate's
ex-husband uh he's a real dude
and it was a great excuse to to reach
out to him
uh and he was completely flattered that
i had
talked about him in a talk in 1997
and uh and he was happy to be back
uh for the talk in 2021 so
hey y'all chuck says hi he
uh ran a comics
mailing list when
he yeah his full-time job was as a
grocery store stock clerk
for a decade my college roommate came
from an economically less advantaged
background
got her ivy league degree and moved back
to where she came from as if
the whole college thing had never
happened and married her high school
sweetheart
and that's the grocery store stock clerk
uh
and he chuck said that he actually made
enough money
off of his comics list that he had to
file taxes with it
uh and he now works as an insurance
analyst
uh so it's a a happy story with
a happy ending james i found that for
you uh
and it was really fun to uh have an
excuse to reconnect
um but these questions i'm still
thinking about them
even if uh the 1997 phrasing is a little
cringy
so let's move on to my talk for today
is human activity changing the climate
how do you know i walked around
tsrb uh back when people actually worked
together in the same building and asked
people that question
and hear the answers i got someone said
i've read abstracts of a few scientific
studies and heard reports on the science
on the science on news sources i trust
someone else said i read one study all
the way through and beyond that
heard about it on the news i've never
actually read any climate science
but i've heard news reports how do you
know
that human activity is cl changing the
climate
isn't it interesting to think about
weight i'm i'm abs
absolutely certain about this but how do
i how did i form
that certainty where did it come from
uh one person i spoke with had empirical
evidence she said i took a trip to
alaska recently
we had to walk two hours to get to the
glacier they told me that just a few
years ago the glacier was right there
you didn't have to walk to get to it at
all
everyone here is relying on sources they
trust
to form opinions so
this raises the question wait what is
knowledge anyway
so uh i'm gonna review some philosophy
today
and try and apply it to the internet and
then
problematize the question of how useful
this is
and what we as hci researchers can do to
make philosophy useful to us
in our practice so the formal
definition of knowledge is justified
true belief
which just leads us to more questions
what does it mean for a belief to be
justified
and what does it mean for something to
be true uh and i'm going to talk about
them in that order even though that
feels a little backwards but i think
it's easier to explain that way
so when you learn something
when are you justified in believing it
how do you make a decision
i should this thing that i was just told
uh
how do i decide whether to believe it or
not if
i if you're on a game show and i say
uh the contestant on the game show says
i just know the car is behind door
number three
even if the car is really behind
door number three that is not knowledge
that was luck it might have been there
because you didn't have a reason to
believe
the car uh was behind door number three
unless of course the stage hand
whispered in your ear hey pick door
number three
that one has the car so you have to have
a
reason for believing something now there
are two approaches to justification
uh i mean there are a lot of approaches
but two central ones one of them is
evidentialism
evidential evidentialism says beliefs
must be supported by evidence
and beliefs can be derived from basic
beliefs
basic beliefs are things you learn
through your senses
and spontaneously formed beliefs can be
basic if they are
a proper response to experience
non-basic beliefs are derived from basic
ones
so for everything you believe you have
to have evidence
all the way down the chain uh
to for why you believe that and then why
for
this why you believe that and then why
you believe that
uh and all the way down to some bedrock
of basic belief so uh
there's a question of to what extent
this is useful in practice because
it's almost impossible for every little
thing
we want to know about to research it all
the way down
to the bedrock of basic belief
uh and i think this problem that no
you can't research everything down to
the base is
expresses one of the core problems of
the internet today
uh this just isn't practical
so a second approach to justification is
reliablism
reliabilism says a belief is reliable if
it's the result of a reliable cognitive
process uh and i love this example from
richard feldman
uh compare a novice bird watcher and an
expert
bird watcher together in the woods
seeking out the rare pink spotted
flycatcher
a bird flies by and each person
spontaneously forms
the belief that there is a pink spotted
flycatcher there
the expert knows this to be true but the
novice is jumping to conclusion
out of excitement the expert has a
well-founded belief but the novice does
not
so uh in this view of justification you
judge the reliability of the process
that generated the idea and this is a
little more practical to use
in practice so within this framework one
might say
the new york times is generally a
reliable source now modulo
some epic failures they've made in the
past will
maybe excuse those maybe not in general
if you uh believe the new york times
you're making a reasonable decision
in the absence of evidence to the
contrary it's fair to say the new york
times is a reliable cognitive process
um okay so
something uh in order for something to
be
knowledge uh you have to be justified in
believing it
and it has to be true but what does it
mean to be true
anyway uh so
we see the world through our senses
all our representations of the world are
approximations i was a physics major
undergrad and as a
freshman physics major i thought that we
were learning the
approximate solutions to solve problems
because we were just
little physicists and when we were big
grown-up physicists
we would learn the real solutions of
course i quickly learned that that was
silly
everything is always an approximation
whether we're thinking about mental
representations or external physical
representations
like things we write down or record and
some make recordings in some fashion
they're all always rep approximations
this is a great story uh by borges uh
of expressing the fact that the only
perfect map
of the territory is the territory itself
and everything else is approximate uh
there is one perfect representation the
universe is a representation of itself
a perfect one uh but everything else
you're making approximations and you
make those approximations through what
you perceive with your senses
um so uh is that a chair
if i said use the raised hand feature if
you uh
if you think that's a chair i think most
of you i hope would raise your hands
that that's a chair uh
how do we know that that's a chair the
objective view of thank you for all the
raised hands yes you see it
yeah it's a chair uh so
uh the objective view of reality
says uh the chair exists
and is knowable the subjective view of
reality
says we're trapped within our subjective
perceptions and i can't really be sure
the chair is there
i love this compromise by hillary putnam
of internal
realism internal realism says okay
smarty pants
uh yes all our perceptions are
subjective
but we all agree there's a chair there
if it's totally subjective why do
all 135 people on this
seminar all agree that there's a chair
and the answer is the chair exists
i can't prove to you that the chair
exists
but i'm going to explain the shocking
total correlation in our purely
subjective perceptions
by saying that our subjective senses are
perceiving something which is actually
there the world exists
so the world exists but is
understandable through subjective senses
uh subjective and fallible senses
so um okay the world exists but is only
knowable through
fallible senses how do we agree
on what's true uh
littorr and wilgar argue that the
process of something becoming true
is social let's talk about the
uh the process of something becoming a
scientific fact
the example is the unit i'm using here
is the unitary charge on the electron
uh when they first wrote their paper in
you could say that milliken and fletcher
claim that the charge on the electron is
unitary
as it became more accepted
you might change that to since the
charge on the electron is unitary
citation militant and fletcher and then
uh finally in the third stage you don't
even need to mention
a militant inflector e yeah i know
the charge on the electron is unitary
what just happened
going from someone claims x to
x is true here's a ref to no just x is
true i don't even need a ref
is a process of social acceptance of the
idea
the more people believe something the
more it is
true now uh socially constructed
knowledge is sometimes wrong
uh the uh we make mistakes all the time
but what we all agree is true
is the best version of what is true that
we have
at any given moment so so far we know
the world exists
we perceive it through subjective senses
and we decide what's true through social
agreement through the social
construction of knowledge
so the next question we have to ask is
what are good practices
for achieving that agreement uh i love
this theory of virtue epistemology it's
my new favorite thing
it's a synthesis of virtue ethics and
epistemology
and it argues that dealing with
knowledge appropriately is a lifelong
journey
and to do so we strive to embody
epistemic virtues
uh good habits and ways of dealing with
knowledge
so i need to take a quick detour here to
explain virtue ethics
i have been teaching basic ethical
theory to our undergrads for
uh 15 or so years uh and
more and more uh uh i think uh
if you made me teach only one theory it
would absolutely
be virtue ethics and uh you know
continuism is nice utilitarianism is
nice virtue ethics is
is uh by far to me uh the most profound
uh so at virtual ethics
comes from has its roots in aristotle
and asks the question what kind of a
person do you want to be
uh embodying the virtues that you choose
is the best way to achieve eudaimonia
which
translates roughly as the kind of
happiness that is worth having
so say that you choose honesty as a
virtue that you wish to
embody learning to be honest is a
lifelong journey uh
the uh i love um
in the literature on on virtue ethics
they write
that uh a truly honest person
is so honest that they're honest in all
their dealings they're honest in their
thoughts
they are not amused by tales of
dishonesty
and i i read that passage and i think i
was doing well until that last one
oh well uh i think uh maybe
uh i need to work on this virtue if i'm
still amused by tales of dishonesty
can't win them all
in other ethical theories
you could use them for things like
what's the answer to this ethical
dilemma
virtue ethics says that embodying a
virtue is a lifelong journey
and you can always be better at it and
it requires practical wisdom knowing how
to go about
doing this in a logical way
uh the um so
virtue epistemology is a combination of
virtue ethics and epistemology
and virtue epistemologists say there are
epistemic virtues
that we can all strive to embody this
particular list of
epistemic virtues is by here's mink
i could give you three different lists
every
virtual epistemologist has their own
list of what the epistemic virtues are
we could think about things like
curiosity intellectual autonomy
intellectual humility uh open-mindedness
courage tenacity it's interesting to
think
about what it means to how would we
operationalize these definitions
and are these ideas actually useful to
us
as designers of technology that
manipulate information
uh it's an interesting list so i'll come
back to that later
so within a virtue epistemology
framework
knowledge is a collaborative achievement
it's hard and it's not something you do
alone it's something that groups of
people do together
uh john greco has this great analogy to
a soccer pass
playing in a soccer game ted receives a
brilliant almost impossible pass
with the defense out of position and
goalie lying prostrate on the ground
ted kicks the ball into the net for an
easy goal
uh the process of achieving knowledge
is collaborative between our midfielder
and our striker
uh the midfielder did most of the work
and the striker kicked it into the goal
and together
they achieved something uh
you as someone considering what to
believe you need to
decide when to believe someone that's
the problem of testimony
uh and the question here for us as
internet researchers
is uh when i receive information on the
internet when am i justified in
accepting it as true
so uh the problem of testimony in
epistemology
is of critical and central importance to
our work in information sciences hci
and social computing
okay so so far we know that knowledge is
socially constructed
and the more something has been
carefully reviewed
the more credibility it has the
mechanism
for social construction of knowledge in
science is peer review
so here's how peer review works uh
for a journal for example three people
read a work they're all
on experts of they're all experts on
every part of the content of the work if
there's any
uh subject matter in the thing they're
reviewing that they're not familiar with
of course they learn all about it
if there are any references cited that
have they have not
personally read that are cited in the
manuscript then they read them carefully
before doing the review
okay maybe not maybe that's not really
how peer review works
uh in science uh i
i think it's important when we think
about reliability of information
think about how peer review really works
in practice
not how it works in some idealistic
fairy tale the process has strengths and
weaknesses and one of the biggest
challenges for the reliability of peer
review
is interdisciplinarity when i review
something these days it's
almost inevitable that it draws from
multiple fields and there'll be an
area of what it's referring to that i
know well and two-thirds of it that i
don't know at all
and i just take the authors at their
word
and i hope that the other two reviewers
know about the other parts of it which
is sometimes true and sometimes not
um the more carefully something
is reviewed the more credible it is
so i started off the title of this talk
and the title of my book is should you
believe wikipedia
so if you want to answer the question
should you believe
wikipedia the question you need to ask
is how is content on wikipedia reviewed
so um i want to give you an example of
a a particular page and i
picked for this example john roberts uh
wikipedia page
next time someone is becomes a
justice of the u.s supreme court or
becomes pope
uh look at their wikipedia page as it
happens
it is a thing of great beauty to watch
uh john roberts's page
was uh created in may 2005
and at the time was 182 words through
the end of july of that year there were
nine edits
and then justice roberts was nominated
for the supreme court
um cheers roberts his original page
remember on wikipedia you can look at
every past version of
every page uh and this is
the version of robert's page before his
nomination it's
you know it's a paragraph this is the
whole thing uh
and says he's a potential nominee to the
court uh
says uh when he was born uh where he got
his degree
uh what his current job is uh and that's
about it
okay so um
on the day roberts was nominated for the
supreme court there were 31 edits
by the end of that month there were 1200
uh
and uh the current version of roberts's
page has gone from 200 words to 6800
and it includes a complete concordance
to all of his judicial opinions
uh while he was a supreme before he was
on the supreme court and while on the
supreme court
uh it's comprehensive uh and truly
impressive
uh the uh and and here's just the
the first couple paragraphs uh it is
a thing of beauty to watch these things
evolve
where literally 1200 edits were made in
the course of a couple weeks
and the whole piece of information
evolved
over time okay so uh
let's compare the review processes
between a high quality peer-reviewed
journal article and a wikipedia page
for a journal article uh well we have
three expert reviewers who
review it uh maybe go through it a few
times and then it's fixed
uh and once we're done with the review
uh it's
uh not changeable anymore wikipedia for
a popular page there are literally
thousands of reviewers now those
reviewers have
varying levels of expertise some of them
are uh
experts and some of them are not uh then
but the non-experts may have
knowledge of wikipedia formatting or
grammar or
uh other sorts of things vandalism is
typically repaired in seconds and it's
updated continuously if something
notable and new happens to someone uh
the uh it's updated in
uh often seconds i
during the presidential inauguration
this year i watched uh
the page of uh uh
pages of kamala harris and joe biden and
uh there you can't make this up these
guys are so
awesome um they were
sworn in a little before noon but
they're only supposed to take
office at noon so someone
updated biden's page to say president of
the united states
when he took the oath of office and
someone else undid it with a comment
saying he's not president until noon
even if he took the oath
and then it precisely knew and someone
put
the statement that he was president to
the united states back again
kind of amazing to watch um so
for a popular wikipedia page if you
think about the degree of review as a
measure of the reliability of
the information this is really
impressive
for a less popular page the story is
different
this is the page for the massachusetts
state house
it has a tag that it needs additional
citations for verification
uh if you'll see uh on
uh the bottom of this page it says
uh that the murals under the dome were
painted by
artist edward brodney who had won
a competition as part of a wpa
initiative to paint them because
rodney had no money
to pay models he used his mother
uh and sister and brother as models
and uh so the the model for uh columbia
queen of the ocean is his sister norma
rodney um the
uh okay
there's no real citation for the fact
that norma brodney
is the model it's there because
i put it there norma was my grandmother
now when i edited this page a very long
time ago you could sometimes get away
with putting something
unsourced on wikipedia um please don't
delete it i've been good don't hurt me
uh but uh the uh
this has managed to stay on wikipedia
for a while
even though i don't know what source we
would use to show you that i promise you
that it is true
uh the um uh
so how would you compare the page on the
massachusetts state house
to the page on john roberts this is much
less reliable i just showed you
something unsourced
that i added why can we get away with
this unsourced statement on the page
about the massachusetts state house
because no one but my mother cares about
the murals in the massachusetts state
house
nobody's looking uh an on
a less well-known page is much less
reliable
than a popular page can i ask the
question about this yeah absolutely
so um you know you're saying now
it's harder to get away with this can
you talk a little bit about the rule
that stuff needs to be sourced but
clearly
you have that knowledge and unless it's
been cited in some kind of publication
it's like you're not allowed to put the
knowledge into wikipedia and that seems
to be problematic in its own sense like
for example
my brother's wikipedia page has an
incorrect
fact about what country he was born in
and i
can't change it i know where he was born
yet
you know somebody has a fake source or
an incorrect source and
so how do you get to truth when um yeah
it's like that um it's it's a limitation
and in general the
quality of sources is a limitation of
wikipedia in general
uh if you wanted you could put up a blog
post
explaining where your brother was born
and then put the citation to your blog
post on wikipedia and you might get away
with that so you're saying you can make
in direction to a low quality source and
yeah which isn't what we want right what
we want is high quality source there's
also the problem of a reference loop and
this happens a surprising degree of the
time and this is
absolutely a weakness of wikipedia so
here's how this goes
uh a journalist is writing an article
and
uses wikipedia as a source
and doesn't cite it they take some info
from wiki there's something uncited on
wikipedia
a journalist writes an article and
copies the information from wikipedia
into the article uh then
later someone else comes back and says
oh
there aren't enough citations on this
page i will search for a citation for
this fact
they do an internet search and they find
the journalists article
so the appearance of uh support for the
reference is created when in fact there
is none
uh so the strength of citations and
citation loops
and hey how do i tell people that's
really normal
uh these are all things that i think
could be improved
uh so um uh
my argument is that a popular page
is arguably the most accurate
form of information ever created i
really mean that
it's crazy how careful this stuff is and
how
uh well updated and comprehensive and
how carefully checked
you can even look at a page on a highly
controversial topic and you'll be
shocked at how reliable it is a less
popular page like the massachusetts
state house is a whole different story
is popularity um easy for people to read
based on just i know john roberts is
popular or do you like
look for how many edits there are is
there some kind of
indicator that i as a user could go oh
that's probably a reliable page or not
right and there have been a number of
research projects to
create visible metrics of how reliable a
page is
and some of them are i mean the easy no
it is not easy to see that and that is a
problem
uh there have been some research
projects that generate metrics of
reliability
some of them are as simple as how often
it's been edited some of them
are uh more complex for example
uh looking at okay who are the specific
people who edited this page
and uh are what is their reputation as
an editor is this person
a reliable cognitive process uh so
uh you know i i do think we could use
some more strongly visible metrics there
is a little bit of that
in uh the warning on the massachusetts
state house
page saying that uh the
this needs additional citations that's
one
very visible indication that this isn't
as reliable as you think
but yes we absolutely need more and this
is a great example
of where understanding the uh the
underlying nature of the construction of
knowledge helps us to be better software
designers to think
directly on what is important in this
design
um so the affordances of wikipedia are
well matched to the social construction
of knowledge
uh we have things like revision history
you can see every past version of every
page
uh talk pages every page has a place
where people can discuss the content
and try and come to consensus wiki
projects
are pages that organize people who are
interested in a particular topic
so for instance there's wiki project
sharks and wiki project medicine
and they'll do things like say hey uh
we have a collaboration of the week
let's all
make the article about uh thresher
sharks better this week
and everyone who's part of wiki projects
sharks will all
uh prioritize working on thresher sharks
for the week
uh they'll do things in wiki projects
like rating the quality of pages okay
these are our a quality pages these are
b these are c
uh and then that can help direct
volunteers attention to
places that need it more uh
interestingly many people don't know
that the policy pages of wikipedia
are themselves editable by anyone
if you were to make an edit without
getting consensus first on the talk page
it would be immediately
reverted but you can go and make changes
to the policy
on biographies of living people uh and i
did make one once which was an
interesting experience
so um an old joke says wikipedia doesn't
work in theory it only works in practice
except maybe if we look at the right
theory maybe it does work in theory
as well as in practice because the
affordances of the software
are so well matched to this process of
social construction
of knowledge um
so i want to pop up a level and ask
a bigger question i've been uh
talking about philosophy is this
actually useful
uh i think that in this case
we can leverage our understanding
about the nature of truths and knowledge
to be better designers of internet
systems
uh the um and
for example uh to facilitate social
construction of knowledge we need
opportunities for people to review
content
as indicated we need visibility of the
degree
of review of content we need support for
consensus formation
the and this applies obviously to
uh you can think about a lot of these
affordances are there in wikipedia what
would it mean
to redesign uh twitter or reddit
to have more of these affordances to do
more successful knowledge building it's
an interesting question
you might think about further how we
might scaffold the process of evaluating
testimony
the whole internet right now is the
problem of testimony
how do i know what to believe and again
uh metadata on
the provenance of information and the
credibility of sources
is critical uh
so i told you i was going to come back
to these epistemic virtues
and and this is uh something i've been
thinking a lot about
how useful it is uh so
could i pick one of these epistemic
virtues
and say i'm going to read everything the
philosophers have said about it
let's say intellectual humility
and come up with a
more precise definition and then
leverage this in the design of an
internet system
uh it's a really provocative question is
that going to work or is that a doomed
endeavor
uh i don't know i i think
the answer i've come up with so far is
that
i found these useful to keep around
rolling around
in my head but it's a little bit of a
heavy lift to go
from the philosophical literature on
intellectual humility to
ah wow well we did an experiment and we
tried to see are people willing to
change their mind
and we use this as a measure of humility
and this helps us to design
better information systems in the
following way
that is a long process but it's an
interesting one to think about
uh the um uh i was looking at this paper
the other day
on uh vulnerability in social epistemic
networks uh the um
uh just as an example so a philosophy
and hci
are different approaches to knowledge in
a fundamental sense
and a lot of philosophy is true uh we
think
but hard to make useful so let's look at
this uh notion of vulnerability in
social epistemic networks
um uh sullivan et al
uh looked are philosophers who
are also nerds i love these guys uh
and they looked at uh
the the problem of
having the appearance of multiple
sources for a piece of information when
there's only one
uh so uh the red dot
uh thinks that they got
this piece of information from three
sources but in fact all three of those
sources
also got uh the the information from the
same original source so in fact there's
only one source
uh and so the the question here then and
and they talk about this as a vulnerable
testimonial network
uh and the question they raise in their
paper is could you
actually turn this into something useful
uh and in order to turn it into
something useful you
need a whole lot of information about
where
every piece of information came from and
when i think about the data
challenge of figuring out
that this false appearance of multiple
sources
exists how to actually do that in
practice is hard
uh the uh but i think it's promising
i think uh there's some synergy here
that could be productive
so uh this talk is the title chapter of
my book should you believe wikipedia
online communities and the construction
of knowledge
uh the book is mostly actually not about
wikipedia
it's about design of online communities
and
i have chapters on the nature of
community
on uh the nature of collaboration
the should you believe wikipedia chapter
that this talk is based on is online
uh thinking about knowledge construction
and how
the social construction of knowledge
changes how we think
uh a chapter on online identity uh
one on bad behavior uh and how we manage
it
uh which is increasingly an entire
industry
and uh oddly uh part way through
late in the writing of the book i
realized that i needed to
add an additional chapter on business
models
i think that how business models
shape the design of systems is in many
ways
should be promoted to a top level
concern
for the study of socio-technical systems
uh and finally uh
take a little time to reflect on how we
can
redesign this medium to bring out the
best in us all
uh this is uh coming out this year uh
i'm supposed to get a mail about what
the cover is gonna look like
uh in another week or two uh which is
exciting uh
and uh i hope you all will find it
interesting
um i i wanna thank um
the social epistemology network uh
facebook group
who are very patient with me uh my
students
my editor lauren cowells at cambridge uh
terry winograd for inviting me to speak
to you all in 1997.
michael for inviting me to speak to you
all this year
and michelle for uh doing such a lovely
job of organizing
uh my schedule and i would love to have
a conversation and take questions thank
you
all right thank you so much amy i saw
you had a question earlier do you still
want to
pop that one in well i was
i was thinking about extremes in um in
your
um point about the more popular pages
the more reliable it is
so that seems to make a lot of sense in
the in the middle but i'm wondering
things like you know george bush donald
trump you know
president obama things that become super
popular or maybe those are special
because they're polarized
i remember because they all get locked
down right so then there's something
else that's taking place it's not just
purely popularity i wonder if you have
anything to say
about some of those there is a lot more
to wikipedia than appears on the surface
uh and the those
mechanisms for example of
uh sometimes locking a page sometimes
restricting a page to people who have
over 500 edits
i have 450 edits i have had 450 edits
for a really long time and a lot of
pages
uh are locked to people who don't have
500 edits i think
um i need to put on my fun summer to-do
list
making 50 more nice constructive edits
to wikipedia
all of those mechanisms are important
and i i think
studying them in detail is important
and the ways that people use
machine learning to help a river
vandalism
uh the ways that people
develop kind of professions in what they
pay attention to
all of these things i think are it's
such a
wonderful model and my assertion
is that we can learn from that model uh
things that are applicable to the design
of different other systems
thanks we've got a couple questions that
are
both circling around i think the same
issue i'll read them both out then you
can sort of
uh synthesize or or select as as is your
as is your want
asks you know you said if over 300
people say that there's a chair then the
chair is no longer subjective but
objective
wondering are you suggesting that if
there's something that can
you know quote unquote make the majority
of people believe something's true
that it automatically becomes the
reality and it's also asking a similar
question saying
if knowledge is similar is socially
constructed how do we deal with the
possibility that the mainstream
consensus on a given topic is wrong but
so widespread is to
appear reliable dude you're swimming in
it
yeah that's a problem congratulations
welcome to the problem that we find
ourselves up to our eyeballs in
there are a lot of people who
believe crazy stuff these days
absolutely insane
um and uh so
social consensus is the way that we
decide what's true but that doesn't mean
that we're right
uh but uh now we're in schredinger's
catland
is it alive or dead if i can't tell if
it's alive or dead without killing it
it's kind of
a a little bit of a moot question it's
dead
so yes
those are those are the questions and
that's what's broken
and that's what we need to find ways to
fix i just i'm gonna follow up on that
if that's what's broken can you
just point toward how like what would
you do here right that's
that seems like a very fundamental
challenge of saying
you know if if the majority of us are
wrong
then we've socially constructed the
wrong knowledge what does
a sociotechnical system do about that
and what other what else can it do
you know do we have philosopher kings i
have a student who
is currently working on a paper where
they
asked uh i found a bunch of people who
posted
false stories on the internet
and asked interviewed the people who
posted them about those stories
and what we found was that the people
fall into groups
uh one group literally stopped the
interview
and said i didn't realize that was false
hold on a second i'm gonna take it down
okay now we can go back to talking um
another group at the far other extreme
said you are a victim of the globalist
conspiracy uh fact
checkers are that story is true the fact
checker that said that it was
false is uh incorrect
and you're deranged if you think that
story is false
there were some people also in the
middle who said
you know you said it was marked
false by snopes but stops is just this
liberal husband and wife team and i just
don't trust them
uh ex-husband and ex-wife long story i i
just don't trust snokes
uh the uh so
the people fall into these different
categories and i think
the group in the middle is the one that
we need to work with
the people who say ah you're part of the
globalist conspiracy
i i ain't going there i can't help or
maybe i can help them eventually but
that's hard
the people who say look i just don't
like your fact checker
uh i think you can have a conversation
with them and that we can design
information systems that are
easier to interrogate and easier for
people with a variety of backgrounds to
say
okay yeah i actually buy that
so the solution is to embed the
epistemology into the design of the
system like this is how we prove
something
i think people fall into different
groups and uh there
are different groups that we need to
address
and they're different solutions uh we're
dividing these groups into personas
and i think we have different
information solutions for the different
personas
i guess there's even a deeper one too
for me which is i really like the
epistemic virtues that you laid out but
we obviously have a lot of variance in
what values you know different folks
have
so you know um believing something to be
real versus believing something to
you know take down the powerful those
are very different beliefs so where
where
isn't that part of the equation like so
it's not just the designing of the
system bringing epistemology but also
like
how do we you know create
these kinds of shared epistemic virtues
right well in uh
i think there's a lot to be said for
zonic
uh that we need more
smaller online venues with shared
assumptions
and uh fewer
giant platforms where we have to agree
on standards for absolutely everyone
so i used to make students in my online
communities class look at
a long time ago do a comparison between
two usenet groups or later became google
groups
uh alt feminism and social
feminism and uh the alt hierarchy was
unmoderated
and you could say anything and the soch
hierarchy
the group social feminism was moderated
to join social feminism you had to agree
on certain values about feminism and
then
starting with those shared values you
could have a conversation on next steps
so you had kind of thoughtful
discussions of
of feminism on social feminism and all
that feminism was just a flame fast
uh exactly you know kind of in-cell sort
of
stuff that you might worry about um
now so
on the other hand if you wanted to have
a thoughtful discussion
about how statistics about the wage gap
are calculated
and questioning them you would not be
welcome on social
feminism right so maybe we need a third
space
uh where that kind of conversation is
welcome
we need different spaces with different
ground rules and i believe we need
more uh non-profit spaces
one of the fundamental arguments i end
up making in the book
is that i don't believe that the profit
motive
can ever make the right thing happen for
either
individuals or communities
and that what we need is more public
platforms
whose fundamental goal is not to
maximize shareholder value
but is to uh create certain outcomes for
individuals
and for communities
and we need lots of small ones so you
can pick
the the one that suits you i don't want
to inflict my values on you
but there should be lots of choices
rather than these giant totalizing
platforms
uh where they have to moderate to the
least common denominator
did you want to jump in uh yeah actually
i now had a different question i guess
than the one i was originally going to
post hi amy i think a lot of what she
pointed out as motivation is wikipedia
and a lot of what impressed you about
wikipedia was the speed at which
knowledge could be corrected or fact
checked or confirmed and
a lot of what powers that is the scope
and scale i mean obviously wikipedia is
the sort of like
unique jewel of the internet in that
it's not for profit and somehow is
successful
despite all of the reasoning about what
would make a social computing system
successful
um so how do you think about this
trade-off between
having fragmented sort of platforms
where people can adopt different norms
around epistemology
and the idea that scale brings with us
this ability um
for these things to happen at the rate
that makes wikipedia work
you're making my head hurt sorry
you're right uh it may i
i uh you're right uh in the case of
wikipedia the scale
is part of its power uh so i just argued
against scale
uh and and now you're making a
compelling argument for why scale is
sometimes powerful
but there's no reason why we can't have
both that we need some big platforms and
some little ones
um the the thing that wikipedia has in
common
with uh the vision i articulated is its
non-profit nature
and my my question was i think we were
talking
kind of earlier about like socially
constructed knowledge
and how we don't really know whether
it's like
true or false at times and my question
is like
whether it's true or false do you think
it's important that we
build on these assumptions anyways
because i kind of pulled the example
in like my proof writing classes like we
build on
assumptions that we may or may not know
are true or not
but we still like make important
revelations from these
so what do you where's your stance
on that i'm not 100
sure i understand uh the
uh the question i'm reading in the chat
michael asking you all to help my
wikipedia page thank you it's very
crafty
i i would be so grateful uh the um
uh you know the one thing you get from
uh hanging out with epistemologists
is uh a definite sense that truth
matters
uh and that that you know so
remember i started off with this model
that the world exists but is only
knowable through our subjective
perceptions
uh i i do think we can be wrong and
correcting things when we're wrong is
important
um and no it's not anything goes there's
such a thing as just being
wrong uh and now
can you sometimes uh come
to positive consequences from slightly
shaky premises
of course but that's called luck and
but what's our alternative here we work
as hard as we can to get our premises
to be solid and to build on them hi
um you just said something really
interesting that i want to react to but
i don't have a really
super well uh formulated question so i'm
going to try to struggle through it um
which is the idea that it's valuable to
have
a bunch of different platforms with a
bunch of different value sets which
i certainly agree with but this week in
particular we've seen a lot of
conversations
about um universal standards for speech
and
in particular international human rights
law as it
uh applies to platform governance
um so i guess my question is
do you have a reaction to the search for
a universalism
in platform governance is there
something there or is that a
um a feudal pursuit
well i mean there's certainly um
some things that shouldn't be allowed
anywhere
uh so
i i think i agree with your suggestion
that there's
a bedrock of look i don't care who you
are certain things are just not okay
uh the and above that dead minimum
uh we need a little more tolerance for
difference
and some of this is a very uncomfortable
conversation we could have a long chat
about gab
and and uh parlor and how we feel about
them uh
the uh uh i
tend to come down on the free speech
side of things
and say you know look uh
the remedy for bad speech is counter
speech and
uh i don't want the government
or uh other bodies
telling me what i can and cannot say but
this
is complicated and shockingly
controversial uh
and i discussed this in detail in the
book but uh
i i do think uh
rational people could disagree on these
issues
uh you know there's some
awful stuff out there how can we allow
that
on the other hand uh
there's totalitarian governments um
and uh the government of
india censoring tweets about how bad the
covet crisis is
uh the uh you know
uh i'm not sure i want to let government
so i believe twitter censored
uh tweets critical of modi uh because
they were legally compelled to uh that's
not cool
so what's the purpose of this whole
medium if the government of india can
censor criticism of its handling of
uh the pandemic so i think i come down a
little more on the side of
yeah there'll be some horrible stuff but
uh we don't want
censorship but i rational people could
come down on a lot of different spots on
the spectrum this is hard
one final thought i guess and i say
final only because we're almost out of
time here
um you know what about the process that
we
the rules we choose to follow and whose
voices are sort of
amplified or cut out of that in the
sense that there
may be approaches taken through
like debates on twitter or or
discussions on talk pages on wikipedia
and so on
that i think we've seen make some
you know privileged some voices and not
others uh
based on who feels comfortable
participating and in what environments
and i think that complicates this whole
notion of
you know what what social constructive
knowledge
is or whose knowledge it's capturing you
know like whose truth
is a way of putting it i'm just curious
if you have
thought about alternative designs that
that might address that issue better
or if not um why why you know what we
have now is maybe
you know the best that we can come up
with yet sort of maybe not an ideal but
again maybe the best we know of
yeah i um michael uh
i think that problem is critical really
critical whose voice is getting
amplified
uh and you know the suggestion i made
before that we have
different spaces with different sets of
values and assumptions
uh i think can partially address that
uh the uh but you know when you
when there's a a big space
that uh and you're saying go to the
smaller space
you're saying uh you're going to get a
lot less
attention for
the ideas if you move and if you're if
you're just creating echo chambers
how does that help uh but
but then the question is whose
responsibility is it to answer this
problem
right i mean the the commercial
platforms are their responsibility is
clear it's to their shareholders
um to maximize shareholder value
uh so i i do think there's a value here
of helping a diversity of voices to be
heard
uh and it's something that we need to
consciously work towards
and it's not going to magically happen
if we don't thank you guys so much
yeah thanks so much for joining us i
will call it here
um amy i'm sure would be happy to
continue this discussion
in some day in person now uh
through virtual means or feel free to
drop her an email
or read her book when it is uh out with
cambridge university press
something something something maximizing
uh bruckman value
um so thank you again for for joining us